the golden knights
enjoying a couple days off right now
yeah it's kind of rare for teams at this
point in the
nhl's truncated season but sports
director chris matthews is here to
face off with derek england and good
evening it is monday that means it's
time once again to face off with derek
england
once again our hockey expert is back
with us and derek it is crunch time now
for these uh
these teams looking to really jockey for
position with just a handful of games
left in the season
yeah definitely they you know two games
against colorado two games against
minnesota who they're battling for
you know those top three spots and then
the uh two other games
phoenix um st louis those are there's
four more games that are then they're
fighting for that last playoff spot so
uh there's gonna be some good hockey
coming down the stretch these final
nine games here you know the knights
enjoying a few days off which is kind of
rare at this point in the season it
seems like but
how big of an advantage is that right
now well i think it's huge just get that
rest
those guys have been playing every other
day
not having much practice time so now
they get a little bit of a practice in
work on a few things tweak some things
that they need to tweak and
the biggest thing is just get the rest
you know they had a day off
before they went to anaheim they had two
days off now so
it's all about getting that rest and uh
healing up a little bit i'm sure there's
some
bumped up guys uh there yeah there were
about five guys who didn't play the
other night so it was international
theodore
i was looking at some stats he's one of
the top defensemen and i think it was
number four
uh going into the weekend yeah he's uh
his upside is just huge
he's so good he's uh you know he's one
of those guys that you watch skate and
he just he's so effortless out there
he's
uh and he can skate forever and you know
you guys guys like me are just like how
does that how does that happen
so um he's got great hands great vision
good shot he's
he's the whole package he's great and
he's going to be a top d man for years
to come here
well so the vegas gold knights coming
off that win over the anaheim ducks
and and breaking a franchise now they
have a nine game winning streak new
franchise high
yeah it's uh it's impressive you know
like i think pete said it
doesn't matter who you're you're playing
to win nine games in a row is something
else and
i think that's completely true it's it's
it's hard to win in this league doesn't
matter who you're playing against
everyone wants to end that winning
streak so um to get it
nine games is uh it's a good that's a
good mark
you know recently i'm sure you heard
robin leonard as we talk about his
struggles with the virus
and uh the mental illness which you know
very real for many players and he came
out and and talked about that
those issues and you were up in that
bubble and like you were saying i mean
it's
it's a real thing yeah it's uh you know
being in the bubble it was it was hard
it was
there wasn't a lot of to do i don't want
to say it was like jail but
you're fenced in you're not allowed out
they they did a good job obviously
keeping
anyone from getting it but it was tough
two months in there and
it's similar now they're not supposed to
go out or anything like that so
it's going to take a toll on some guys
for sure all right it's going to be
interesting to see what happens all
right derek we're already out of time
here once again
we'll see you next week as the knights
now host colorado on wednesday that's
going to be a big game
huge game